The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
The title here is the
topic for our class today.
We want to discuss formally
the derivation Optical Bloch
Equations, but usually
when I teach you something,
I have a general concept in mind
and the concept right now here
is, how can we get from unitary
time evolution of a quantum
system to rate
equations anticipation.
And this is sort of the
subject of master equation
open system dynamics, and
this cartoon sort of tells you
what you want to do.
We have a total system, which is
one part we are interested in,
and the other one, often it has
many, many degrees of freedom,
and we don't want to
keep track of them.
But they have one Hamiltonian.
But we are only interested in
how our atomic system evolves,
and we want to find
an equation, which
is no longer a
Schrodinger equation.
How does an initial density
matrix describing our system
develop with time?
And as we will see, in general,
it follows a master equation,
and we want to discuss
what are general principles
of such equations.
But it's very important
here is that we are not
keeping track of what
happens in the environment,
and that's associated here with
a little bucket or trash can.
Every result photons
or such are measured,
the environment is constantly
projected on a measurement
basis, and therefore,
re-introduce probabilistic
element into the part
we don't observe mainly
the part which
characterizes the atoms.
So for that we need the
formalism of density matrix,
and that's where
we want to start.
At the end of last
lecture, I reminded you
that the density
matrix can always
be written as an
ensemble where you
say you have a certain
probability for certain rate
function.
This is always possible,
but it is not unique.
So each of you could actually
create the same density matrix
by preparing a number
of quantum states
with a certain
probability and saying
this is my density matrix.
And also each of you has
prepared different quantum
states.
If you sum them up
in that same way,
you get the same density matrix
and therefore, all observables
or measurements you will do
on your ensemble in the future
will be identical because
the density matrix is
a full description
of the system.
So at that level, it may
look sort of very trivial
that we have
different unraveling.
Unraveling means you
look microscopically
what is behind the
density matrix,
but in your homework
assignment, you
will all show that you can have
a system which have very, very
different dissipation
mechanisms,
but they're described
by the same equation.
So therefore, it's
physically not possible
to distinguish by just measuring
the density matrix what
causes a dissipation.
Of course, if you know
what causes a dissipation,
fluctuating fields
or collisions,
you know more than the
density matrix knows.
Any questions about density
matrix or the agenda
we want to go through today?
Just a quick reminder and
since this was covered in 8421,
and most of you know about
it, I pre-wrote the slides.
The density matrix
is a time evolution.
There is one which is sort
trivial and covered in more
elementary takes, and this
is the Hamiltonian evolution,
and I'm sure you've seen it.
The time evolution, the
unitary time evolution
involves the commutative
of the Hamiltonian
with a density matrix,
and later on, we
want to specialize including
dissipation, including
the environment to the evolution
of a tool evolutionary system
driven by a monochromatic field
And this the famous
Jaynes-Cummings Hamiltonian,
and we can characterize this
system by a density matrix,
but will be very important
is that we distinguish
between populations,
the diagonal parts,
and the coherences.
And if you simply put
this density matrix
into this equation, you find the
time evolution of the system,
and we will refer to
that result later on.
Many of you have
seen it in 8421.
we can parametrize
the density matrix
for the two-level system.
So we can parametrize
the densities
of the two-level system
by a local vector,
r, which is defined
by this equation.
And then the equation
of motion is simply
the rotation of a Bloch
vector on the Bloch sphere,
and it has a
rotational axis, which
is given by-- the
undriven system
rotates around the z-axis.
This is just e to
the i omega naught
t, the normal evolution
of the free system.
But if you divide it with
a monochromatic field
rotation over the x-axis
and the x-axis, of course,
can take your two-level system,
and flip it from the ground
to the excited state.
So it's just a reminder of the
simple unitary time evolution,
but now we want to add
dissipation on top of it.
And what I've decided
that before I discuss
with you Optical Bloch Equation
and master equation in general,
I want to give you
a very simple model.
I really like
simple models which
capture the essence of what
you are going to discuss.
So what I want to use is I
want to use a beam splitter
model I formulated for photons,
but it would also immediately
apply to atoms.
And this model, what
I like about it,
it has all the ingredients
of integration of the master
equation we'll do later
on without the kind
of many indices and
summations and integration,
but it captures every single
bit of what is important.
And I usually like to present
exactly solvable, simple models
where you get it, and
then I can go a little bit
faster for the
general derivation
because you know exactly what
the more complicated equations,
what they are doing.
So in other words, what I
want to derive for you is
we want to have the
following situation.
We have a beam splitter,
and we know everything
about beam splitters
because we talked about them
in the first part of
the course, and we
have a wave function,
which is the input,
and this is a photon.
And we want to understand
after the beam splitter,
how has the system evolved.
In general, it will
be a density matrix,
and what you want
to find out is,
what is the equation
for the density matrix.
Maybe this density matrix goes
through the next beam splitter
and then we want to know
what comes out of it.
And all we have to
apply is the formalism
we developed for the beam
splitter earlier in the course.
Of course, the beam
splitter is not as harmless
as it looks like.
There is another part
and another part one here
brings in the environment,
and for the environment,
we will use the vacuum.
That's the simplest environment.
It's actually
important environment
because it is the environment
we will use all the time when
we discuss spontaneous emission.
We send photons into the
nirvana, into the vacuum
and they disappear, and
this is our modified.
But the other one which
is often not so explicit.
If you send your
photons away, you're
not keeping track
of what happens,
but you could as well
perform a measurement,
and this is what we put in here.
We say those photons
hit a bucket or detector
and measure them,
we observe them.
There's nothing else
we do with them,
so we can as well measure them,
and this being immediately
lead to the equation
for the density matrix.
So this is what you
want to discuss,
and it will have all
the ingredients later
on in a mathematically
simple form
for the derivation
of master equation.
So let's consider a
similar photon for that.
So the wave function,
this is superposition
of no photon and 1 photon,
and the coefficients
are alpha and beta.
And just for
simplifying notation,
I pick alpha and
beta to be real.
So what do we expect to
happen at the beam splitter?
Well, there's a probability
that the photon gets reflected.
Probability to
reflect the photon
and therefore to
observe the photon.
This probability is, of course,
beta square-- the probability
that we have a photon to
begin with-- and then the beam
splitter, remember we
categorized the beam
splitter with angle
sine theta cosine theta.
Sine theta was the
reflection amplitude,
cosine theta, the
transmission amplitude.
So this probability,
which I call P1
is the probability for
reflection and for measurement.
And now naively you
would think what
happens after the system
has passed through the beam
splitter, with a probability of
P1, we've measured the photon.
We know for sure there
is no photon left.
The system is in
the vacuum state,
but then you would say,
well, maybe with probability
1 minus P1, we have
not measured anything.
Nothing has happened
to the wave function,
and that means the wave
function just continuous.
Well as we will
see, this is wrong.
We are missing something.
What we are actually missing
is that if you measure nothing,
the wave function is not sine.
The possibility that we could
have measured something,
changes the wave function.
I will comment on that in much
more detail in a few lectures
down the road when
I derive for you
quantum Monte Carlo
wave function.
I will have a wonderful
discussions with you
about how does non-observation
change a wave function.
So we will talk about
the physics behind it
in some more detail.
Right now, I don't want to
get into this discussion.
I simply want to use our
beam splitter equation,
so we can just take the beam
splitter equation and apply it.
So our output state
is obtained by taking
the operator for
our beam splitter,
and maybe you remember that the
propagation for beam splitter
was discovered by
an operator, which
had a dagger b dagger
a in the exponent.
a and b are the two input nodes.
And the angle of
the beam splitter,
which interpolates between
0% and 100% reflection
transmission is theta.
And we're now looking
for the output
state of the total system.
We're not performing
the measurement yet,
and this is now acting on
the total system, which
is the cross product
of our photon system,
of our system of interest.
And the other
input, which we call
the environment or
the vacuum, is 0.
Well, look a few weeks
back, we have done that all.
The output state is, well,
there was a probability, alpha,
that we had no photon
in the state psi.
And if we have no
photon in the state psi
and no photon in the vacuum,
this is the state 0, 0.
What I denote here
with this second place
is the environment.
And now we have one photon.
We have exactly one photon
with the amplitude beta,
and this photon is split
with cosine theta transmitted
and with phi theta reflected.
If you transmit
it, we have 1, 0.
If we reflect it, we have 0, 1.
And again, this is
the environment,
and here is a photon
in the environment.
So let me just be
clear that this
is where the
environment comes in.
It is a vacuum
state, and here, this
is the output part
for the environment.
This is where we
do the measurement.
And I don't think it matters.
I haven't really told you
which is mode A, which
is mode B. It doesn't
matter, but one, let's say
the environment is
mode B, and the system
evolves in mode
A. As you can see,
I'm using a new
program, which has
some nicer features in
terms of handwriting,
but it is a little bit
rough in scrolling,
so I sometimes have to
scroll back and forth.
So what is our output?
Now, we have two possibilities.
The environment is 0,
or the environment is 1,
and we perform a measurement.
So we have to now go into a
probabilistic description.
So with probability P1, we
have done a measurement,
and our output state is
now the vacuum state.
With probability 1
minus P1, we have not
detected anything in the
vacuum, and therefore, our state
of the system is alpha 0
plus beta cosine theta 1.
Is alpha 0, so it is not beta 1
as naively would have assumed.
It's not the original state.
There is a cosine theta
factor, which we got exactly
from the beam splitter from
the unitary evolution provided
by the beam splitter.
And since these state
is no longer normalized,
I have to normalize
it by alpha squared
plus beta square
cosine square theta.
So now we have done our
measurement probability P1
to detect the photon.
This projects the system
into the vacuum state
with the probability 1 minus P1.
We have that state.
Just one second.
Scroll in the pictures.
Write that down.
In fact, millions
that our system is now
described by a density
matrix with probability P1
and 1 minus 1 minus P1.
With probability P1, we
are in the vacuum state,
and with probability
1 minus P1, we
are in that state, the
denormalized state psi
naught, which I just hold down.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Have you
considered theta
to be some like a dynamical
phase evolution system.
It's very low order
like when you expand it
the first time it looks almost
identical to [INAUDIBLE]
quantum effect maybe.
The environment is measuring the
state in some way, and I mean,
it's the lowest order now.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I Quite
agree that random 0 is just
an example of it.
Pretty much, it's all the same.
Yeah.
What we do here is, I
like the beam splitter
because the beam splitter
provides an exact formulation
of the measurement process.
You really can use
a beam splitter
to discuss what
happens fundamentally
when you perform a measurement.
And the beams splitter is one
typical implementation of that,
but it has all the
features you'll
find in any measurement system.
And especially what
you observe here,
let me just emphasizes is,
the fact that we you do not
make a measurement
is changing the way
function from the initial wave
function psi to psi naught,
we have a factor of
cosine theta here.
And that's also very general.
A measurement perturbs,
modifies your wave function
no matter what the outcome
of the measurement is.
So let me write
it down because we
want to take it
to the next level.
So we have now found in terms of
the beam splitter, angle theta,
and the parameters of the
initial state, alpha beta.
We found the density matrix
after the beam splitter.
Yes.
So what is the next step?
Our goal is to derive the
master equation for the density
matrix, the time evolution
of the density matrix.
So since we want to
discuss the time evolution,
we want to find a
differential equation.
So what we want
to figure out is,
what is the difference
between the output density
matrix and the input
density matrix.
The input was, of
course, pure state
characterized by the matrix
population alpha squared
and beta squared of diagonal
matrix element of alpha beta.
The difference between
the density matrix
is can just calculate
the difference.
You can simplify
things by applying
some trigonometric
identities, so this
is an exact result,
cosine theta minus 1.
Here we have alpha beta
cosine theta minus 1,
and on the diagonal,
we have cosine
2 theta minus 1 divided by 2.
Anyway this is an
intermediate result.
We're interested in the
differential equation.
We want to sort of find out
what happens when we observe,
when we have the density
matrix interacting
with the environment
all the time.
And this can be simulated
by beam splitters
by using many beam splitters
with a small degree
of reflection.
So we want to simplify
this result now
for the case of many beam
splitters, and each of them
has a small tipping
angle, theta,
and for later convenience, I
defined theta to be gamma times
delta t over 2.
That's just my
definition of theta.
So what we have in mind now is
that we start with the system
psi, and we have many such beam
splitters with an infinitesimal
tipping angle.
Each beam splitter has the
vacuum at its input state.
And we always perform
the measurement.
If I take the
equation above, which
I know you can't see anymore,
we find a differential equation
for the density matrix, which is
we find an infinitesimal change
delta over the density
matrix, which looks like this.
So all I've done is, I've
used the equation above,
and I've done a Taylor expansion
in the small angle theta.
And the reason why I brought
in the square root, well,
we get cosine theta.
The first order Taylor expansion
or the lowest order Taylor
expansion from cosine is
1 minus theta squared.
So I get the square
root squared.
So I get gamma,
which appears here,
and then I divide by delta t.
So this is just an exact
mathematical expression,
and the next step is to form
a differential equation.
But before I do that, I want
to emphasize the two features
we are using here.
They sort of enter
automatically,
but these are the
two big assumptions
we make when we derive
a master equation.
The first one is that we
always have a vacuum state
as the input.
So in other words,
the environment
is always in the same state,
which is a vacuum state,
and this is sort of called
a Bohr approximation.
What it means is that we
do a measurement here,
but the vacuum is not changing.
In other words, we are
not overloading the vacuum
with so many photons
that suddenly the vacuum
Is no longer in
the vacuum state.
Or in the case of
spontaneous emission,
the vacuum can just take as many
photons as you dumping into it.
They disappear so quickly that
for all practical purposes,
the environment stays
in the vacuum state.
So this is called the
Bohr approximation.
The environment is not changing.
It has enough capacity you to
be modified by the measurement
process.
And the second thing
which is related
is, the vacuum is always
in the same state,
and there are no correlations
from here to here to here,
there is no memory effect.
Everything is
completely uncorrelated.
So the environment
is uncorrelated.
It has no memory.
It's correlation function
is a delta function,
and this is called
Markov approximation.
So these are the two
effects which are important.
One is no memory
for the environment,
Delta function correlation,
Markov approximation,
and the two, of
course, are related
in the environment is all
of this in the same state.
So remember this is a change
for the density matrix,
and alpha beta where
the original parameters
of the density matrix
for the input state.
So I can now rewrite everything
as a differential equation.
The density matrix
has a derivative
for the diagonal matrix
elements and for the coherences.
Here we have plus gamma.
Here we have minus
gamma 0, 1, 1,
makes sense because
we conserve the trace.
We have unity probability
that we have a stellar system.
And therefore the two
diagonal matrix elements,
the population, the sum of
them cannot change with time.
And for the coherence,
we have gamma over 2.
And if you're familiar with
Optical Bloch Equations, which
we derive next, we
can say that these
means if 0 is the ground state
that the ground state changes
because-- call it spontaneous
emission from the excited
state.
This equation would say that
the excited state decays
with the rate gamma,
and sometimes you
may have wondered about
that there are factors
of two appearing,
which also appears here
that when the excited state
decays with a rate gamma,
we have a factor here
for the coherences, which
is gamma over 2.
So what we have
accomplished in contrast
to let's say Einstein's
equation with the Einstein
a and b coefficient,
which lead to rate
equations for the population,
we have now a new feature.
We have an the equation
for the coherences,
and we find a decay
of the coherences
with half the rate as a
decay of the population.
Questions?
So if you want you could rewrite
this model for photon, which
goes through beam splitters,
undergoes measurement.
You can rewrite it from
atomic wave function
and you measure
whether the atomics
in the excited and ground
state and the equation
for the measurement
performed on the atom
is exactly as the equation by
which the beam splitter acts
on the photon state.
So what I've shown
here it's very
specific for a single
photon because I
could use simple
equations, but everything
is what you find in a much
more general situation.
So before I give you the
general derivation of the master
equation, let me talk
about what we have learned
from this example and what
the general procedure is.
The first thing is our goal
is to find a differential
equation for the density
matrix of the system.
I just remember.
There was one thing
I wanted to mention.
In the previous derivation
with the beam splitter,
I started with a purer
state, and the purer state
developed into a
statistical mixture,
and this statistical
mixture would then
transform the next
beam splitter into
another statistical mixture.
I derived the differential
equation for you
for the first state
from the pure state
to the statistical mixture.
But if you would
spend a few minutes,
you could immediately
show that you
can start with an
elementary density matrix,
look how it evolves
through the beam splitter,
and you get exactly the
same differential equation.
So the general procedure is,
we want a differential equation
how the density matrix
evolves with time.
And this will be obtained
by finding an operator which
acts on the initial
density matrix.
This operator is not
a unitary operator
because we are
performing measurements
through the environment,
even if you don't actually
perform them.
Once we dump something
into the environment,
it's out of our
control and anybody
could go and perform
a measurement,
and so we should assume
that this measurement has
been taken.
It's one of those
quantum mechanical things
that you don't even have to
care whether somebody does it.
The environment does it for you.
So this operator is called
a Liouvillian operator.
It's sometimes called--
and I haven't really
traced down why-- it's called
sometimes super operator.
I know what
superconductivity is,
but I don't know what the super
powers of this operator are,
but that's just a name
which you will find.
The second thing
which we have used
is that the evolution
of this system
can be obtained from the time
evolution of the total system
by performing a trace over
the degrees of freedom
of the environment.
This was exactly
what we actually
did when we said the system
continues with probability P
naught in one state
and probability
P1 in the other state.
The operation which lead
to this density matrix
was exactly the partial trace.
So this is the second
general feature
which we have to implement.
Thirdly, if we could
do one and two exactly,
we would have an
exact formulation
for a small part
of a quantum system
no matter how complicated
the environment is.
In practice, we can
solve the equations only
when we make
simplifying assumptions
about the environment.
One is, it is large,
and more important,
therefore, it's unchanging, and
this is the Bohr approximation.
And the second feature is,
it has a short correlation
time, tau c.
In the beam splitter, I
have made the assumption
that there is no correlation
between different beam
splitters in the
derivation, which
I want to walk you through.
Right now, you
will see explicitly
where the correlation
times enter.
And this is called the
Markov approximation.
And finally, this is number
four, the whole possibility
to derive a master
equation hinges on the fact
that we have different
time scales which
are very different.
We are interested in the
evolution of our system.
We want to know how it relaxes,
and this is on a time scale
1 over gamma.
So we call this slow.
We are interested
in the variation
of our system, the atomic
system or the photon state,
which passes through
the beam splitter,
and this time scale
has to be much slower
than the fluctuations
of the environment.
So therefore, if the
environment has fluctuations,
which in the beam
splitter model where
assumed to be 0, it was
delta function of time,
if that correlation time is
much smaller than the time
it takes for the system
to relax and to evolve,
that opens a window
delta t, and this
is the time scale of
the master equation.
Just to give you one example
for the spontaneous emission,
the correlation
time, tau c, would
be the time it takes the photon
to disappear from the atom.
And the photon has
disappeared from the atom
when it is one wavelengths away.
So typically, the
correlation time
f the vacuum for
spontaneous emission
is one cycle of the
optical frequency.
It's very, very fast.
Whereas typical decay times
of the excited states,
a nano second.
It's six orders of
magnitude slower,
and this is what we describe.
But on a time scale
of a femtosecond
of one optical cycle, the photon
has not detached from the atom
and it could go actually
back to the atom.
During that time, we talked
a little bit about it
when we did this diagrammatic
discussions of resonance
scattering for very,
very early times.
You don't have exponential
decay because you cannot do
the approximations where
we approximated the kernel
by something which was
completely energy dependent.
And so what happens
at such short times,
we encounter here again
in such short times,
we will not have a simple
description of the system.
So the last point,
let me summarize.
Our goal is that we describe the
density matrix of the system,
and we want to find
the Liouville operator
or some matrix which acts on it.
And because we will integrate
over time steps, which
are larger than the
correlation time of the system,
we can also call it, it will
be a coarse-grained evolution.
Any questions about that?
I really like the discussion,
the derivation of the master
equation, how it is presented
in atom-photon indirection.
But it is presented
on more than 50 pages
with many, many equations.
So after giving you all
of the principles, all
of the concepts, I
want to go with you now
over those equations
and point out how
the principles, which we
encountered with the beam
splitter, how they
are now implemented
in a very general context.
I will not be able to give you
all of the mathematical aspects
of it, but I think by now you
know that the book atom-photon
interactions are
actually wonderful.
You can get a lot of conception
information out of it
by looking at the equations
without understanding
every technical detail.
So I would really encourage
you, if there is something which
piques your interest and I
hope there will be things which
you'll find very interesting,
that you go to the book
and read it.
So I'm exactly following
that actually I
used copies of the book.
So we have a
Hamiltonian, which is
describing the atomic system.
It describes the reservoir and
then there is an interaction.
We keep it very general here,
but you may always think well,
the atom is your favorite
two-level system.
The environment is
maybe the vacuum
with all its possible
modes, and the interaction
is the dipole interaction
or the a dot p interaction.
So we start out
with an equation,
which is nothing else
than Schrodinger's
equation for the density matrix.
The time derivation
of the density matrix
is commutative
with the Hamilton.
But it is often useful and
you've seen it many times,
to go to the interaction
representation,
that the time dependence
due to the unperturbed part
of the operator is absorbed
in a unitary transformation,
so therefore, this density
matrix in the interaction
representation evolves not with,
h, because h naught is taken
care of, it only involves due
to the coupling between the two
systems, between the
system and the environment.
So now this equation, we are
interested in a time step delta
t.
And this time step,
delta t remember,
we want to coarse
grain, will be larger
than the correlation
time of the reservoir,
and you will see exactly
where it comes about.
So we want to now do one of
those coarse-grain steps.
We take this equation and
we integrate from time t
to time t plus delta t.
So this is exact here.
But now we want to iterate,
and that means the following.
We have expressed the time
step in the density matrix
by having the
density matrix there.
But now we can do in a
first-order perturbation
theory, we can do one step and
we get the second order result
by plugging the first order
result into this equation.
It's the same we have seen
with our diagrams and such.
We have an exact equation.
It's useless unless we do
something, and what we do is,
we realize that
we can iterate it
because the part we don't
know involves one more
occurrence of the
interaction potential.
And when you plug the nth
order solution in here,
you get the n plus
first order solution.
And this is exactly
what is done here.
And I skipped a
few equations here.
This is what he's
done here, number one.
And number two is, we are
interested in the system,
not in the reservoir,
so therefore we
perform the trace
over the reservoir.
And the trace of the reservoir
for the photon beam splitter
mend, we say we have
two possible states,
we detect a photon or not.
And for the system, we
have now a density matrix
which is probability P naught
in one state, probability
P1 in the other state.
And this is exactly what the
operator partial trace does.
Remember also I want
to really make sure
that you recognize
all the structures.
The time evolution of a density
matrix was a commutator with h,
but in the interaction picture,
it's a commutator with v.
But since we are putting the
first order result in here,
the second order result
is now the commutator
of v with the
commutator of v and o.
It's just we have
iterated one more time.
So the sigma tilde, the
density matrix for our system,
tilde means in the
interaction picture
is now the partial
trace over the reservoir
of the total density matrix.
Tilde means in the
interaction picture.
And the important part
here is that it is exact.
We have not done any
approximation here.
Any questions?
Of course, now we have to
make approximations because we
cannot solve an interactive
problem exactly.
The first one is-- and what
do we want to do in the end?
We want to keep the
first non-trivial term
but to the extent possible, we
want to factorize everything.
We want to get rid of the
entanglement of the environment
in the system and only get
sort of the minimum which
is provided by the coupling.
So this evolves as follows.
The interaction we assume is
a product of two operators.
One operator acts on
the system, one operator
acts on the environment.
So this could be the dipole
acting on the atom, the vacuum
field, e, interacting
with the environment
or it could be p dot a.
Or maybe your system has
a magnetic moment, m,
and the environment consists
of fluctuating magnetic fields.
So we'll pretty much find
in every kind of measurement
that a measurement involves
the product of two operators.
One is an operator
for your system
and one is an operator for the
reservoir of the environment.
And so this is one
thing we want to use,
and now there is one
thing which the moment we
will set in our equations,
there is one thing
which will naturally appear.
Let me scroll back.
What we have here is the
interaction operator, v,
at two different times.
So this means if something
happens at different times
and we integrate over times.
This is a correlation function,
a correlation function
between v at the time t prime
and the time t double prime
and since the reservoir
part of this interaction
is the operator, r, so
what we have here now is,
we have a correlation
between the operator, r,
at two times, which
characterizes the environment.
And now comes an
important approximation.
You remember I said we want to
assume that the environment has
a very short correlation time.
Whenever a photon is emitted,
it appears dramatically fast.
It disappears in
one optical cycle,
and the environment
is sort of reset,
it's back in the vacuum state.
So this is now expressed here
that this product over which
we take the partial trace has
a very short coherence time.
And the fact is
now the following.
We are integrating over a
coarse-grained step delta t,
but this correlation function
goes to 0 in a very short time.
So therefore it will
not contribute a lot.
Let me write that down.
What we are going to approximate
is our total density matrix
is now approximately
factorizing in a density matrix
describing the atomic system.
Well, we describe
the atomic system
when we trace out
the environment.
We describe the environment when
we trace out the atomic part.
And if we now form
the direct product,
we are back to the
total system, but we
have factorized the total
density matrix into two parts.
What we neglect here is a part
which cannot be factorized
which is the
correlated part of it.
But what happens is, since we
are integrating over time steps
delta t and the
correlation decay
in a very, very short
time, the result is
that this complicated part,
which we could never calculate,
is smaller than the first
part by the ratio of the time
where the correlations
contribute over the time delta
t, the time step we
are going to take.
So this is a very
critical assumption.
There is a whole page
or two in the book where
an photon-atom
interaction they discuss
the validity of this
assumption, but I've given you
the physical motivation that we
indicate over much larger time,
and if this time is large
and the correlation is
lost for short time,
they only contribute
with this small
parameter to the result.
So in other words,
this means after-- we
have an interaction between
the environment and the system.
We write it down
in second order,
but the second
order result is now
we evaluated by
factorizing the density
matrix into our system
in the reservoir.
So that means in that sense
if you factorize something,
it looks as if it's
not interacting,
but the trick is the same.
You write down something
to first and second order,
and once you have factored
out the important physics,
now you can evaluate
the expression
by using an approximation,
which is now the approximation
that the density
matrix factorizes.
So with that, this
is the approximation
that we have made that the
correlation time is very short.
And now we have a
differential equation
for the density matrix
sigma, which describes
or atomic system.
We have traced out the
degrees of the reservoir.
And now we want to insert B.17.
You probably don't
remember what B.17 is.
It says that the
interaction operator
is a product of a, the
operator a for the atoms
and r for the reservoir.
So the reservoir part, tau
prime tau double prime,
gives a correlation function.
This is the correlation
function between the operator,
r, at two different
times and the part
which acts on our system, the a
part, is explicitly kept here.
So this is now a
general master equation.
It tells us the time
evolution of the density
matrix in this form.
It looks very
complicated, but this
is because it's very general.
In order to bring it
into an easier form,
we want to now introduce a basis
of states, energy eigenstates
of the unperturbed
system, and write down
all of these operator into
such a basis of states.
But anyway you saw here how
we had an exact equation,
and the main
approximation we made
is that the operator
acting on the environment
has a very short
correlation time.
Any questions?
Well, you're only
a few minutes away
from producing this result
to Fermi's golden rule, which
you have known for
a long, long time.
It's just we have made
very general assumptions.
You see sort of how the
assumptions propagate,
but now if you write it down
for an energy eigenbasis,
you will immediately see
results you have probably
known since your childhood.
So we want to have
energy eigenstates
of the atomic
operators, so this is
sort of ground and
excited state if you
think about a two-level system.
The previous equation,
I have to go back to it.
Our previous equation is
a differential equation
for the density matrix here,
and here is the density matrix.
So now we formulate
this equation
into an energy eigenbasis,
and what do we get?
Well, we get an equation
for the matrix elements,
and what matrix
elements are important?
diagonal matrix elements
which are population
of diagonal matrix elements
which are coherences.
So we pretty much
take this equation,
use the energy
eigenbasis and look,
what do we get for
the populations
and what do we get
for the coherences.
So the structure is
now the following.
That we have our
matrix elements ab.
There is one part which looks
like a unitary time evolution.
This is what comes from
the Hamilton operator.
This is sort of the-- we'll
see that in a moment--
but this is the time
evolution without relaxation
and now we have
something here which
are generalized
relaxation coefficients.
And you will find if
you go further above
that those relaxation
coefficients are directly
related to the correlation
function of the reservoir.
So we can now specify what
happens between populations.
Population means that we
have a differential equation,
let's say between
sigma aa the puller,
and sigma cc, so we
have a rate coefficient
which connects the
population in state A
with the population in state C.
And if you take this expression,
you find several things.
Well, you find
Fermi's golden rule,
in a generalized
way-- that's always
nice-- you find
Fermi's golden rule.
When you integrate over time,
you often get data function,
and you expect to get a
delta function because
of energy conservation.
So you get that, of
course, naturally.
Secondly, we have second
order matrix element,
which you know from
Fermi's golden rule,
but now we have the
following situation
that the matrix element
in Fermi's golden rule
may actually depend on the
state, mu, of the environment.
So you have maybe 10
different possibilities
for the environment,
and Fermi's golden rule
gives you spontaneous
emission, which
is different for
those 10 states.
And naturally, since we have
performed the partial trace
over the environment,
we have all those rates
weighted with the probability
that the environment
is in one of those states.
So what you find here is
a simple generalization
of Fermi's golden rule.
And if you look at the
off-diagonal matrix elements,
for instance, you
want to know what
is this rate, what is the rate
coefficient, which gives you
the time derivative
of the coherence,
and it's multiplied
with the coherence.
You'll find now that in general,
this rate coefficient has
a damping term, but it may
also have an imaginary term.
And I hope you remember when we
played with diagrams, that we
had something similar.
There was something which we
called the radiative shift.
I called it the AC stock
effect of a single photon,
and here it is a
level shift which
comes because the environment
interacts with your system
and it shifts the
levels a little bit.
So in addition to
just relaxation,
spontaneous emission,
and damping,
there is also a dispersive
part, a level shift,
and it has exactly
the same structure.
Let me add that delta
ab is the difference
between the shift of state
b and the shift of state a.
And those shifts have
exactly the same structure.
You have to take the principle
part of something which
has 1 over the
difference of energies,
and we discussed that
this has to be understood
by somewhere adding an
infinitesimal imaginary part
and doing the right thing
with complex function.
It's actually related to
Laplace time difference
between Laplace transformation
and Fourier transformation.
So anyway what I find
sort of beautiful
is that we started with
a most general situation.
We perform the partial trace.
We made one assumption of
short correlation times,
and a lot of things we have
known about quantum system
just pops out in a
very general form here.
Any questions about so far?
Well, the coherences are,
of course, more interesting
than the population.
Coherence is always something
physicists get excited about it
because it captures
something which goes often
beyond classical
system that we have
quantum mechanical coherences.
And what happens is the
coefficient here, which
provides the damping
of the coherence,
just comes out of the
formalism, has two parts.
And one part is
an adiabatic part
and the other one is
a non-adiabatic part.
Well, and that makes sense.
If you have two quantum
states and there
is a coherence, some
phase between the two,
the phase can get lost if you
do a transition between the two
states or one state undergoes
a collision and is quenched.
So you definitely have one
part which is due to the fact
that the quantum states
or the population
changes, and you find that there
is this state-changing part,
which is pretty much
the sum of all the rate
coefficient leading
out of state,
leading to the decay
of state a and leading
to the decay of state b.
In other words, if you have
a two-level system, which
has a coherence and you
have decay of the excited
state and decay of
the ground state,
you would expect that those
decay terms appear also
in the decay of the coherence
between the two levels
and they do, and they appear
with the correct factor of 1/2.
But there is another possibility
and this is the following.
You can have no [INAUDIBLE] of
the population of the state,
but you can still
lose the coherence.
The model you
should maybe make is
that you have spin
up, spin down.
You are not perturbing
the populations
in spin up and spin
down, but the environment
provides fluctuating
magnetic field.
Then due to the
fluctuating magnetic field,
you no longer can keep
track of the phase,
and that means in
your identity matrix
the off-diagonal
matrix elements decay.
And we find that here this
is the second part which
in this book is called
the adiabatic part,
and the physics behind it
is now pure de-phasing.
So it's an independent
way for coherences
to decay independent of the
decay of the population.
Questions?
Collin.
AUDIENCE: Where does the
Markov approximation come in?
PROFESSOR: The Markov
approximation is, so to speak,
the delta function
approximation,
which would say that-- I mean,
I introduced the correlation
function between the
reservoir operator
and said the correlation time
tau c is very, very short.
The Markov approximation
would actually
state that it would actually
say in a more radical way
the correlation time is 0.
And the Bohr
approximation, the fact
that the reservoir
is unchanged came
in when we said
the total density
matrix for the second order
expression just factorizes.
It factorizes into
the environment,
which is just this density
matrix of the environment.
It's not changed by the
interaction with the system.
And this is the
Bohr approximation.
We just use the same expression
for the reservoir independent
of the measurements
the reservoir has done.
Other questions?
Yes, Nancy.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This is
something very general.
Thank you actually
for the question.
Whenever we have some
damping of the population,
the coherence is only
damped with a factor of 1/2.
One way to explain it
in a very simple way
is, that if you have an
amplitude alpha excited
and alpha ground, the
population in the excited state
is this squared.
So you sometimes make the
model that the amplitude decays
with gamma over 2,
but the population
is-- because you take the
product, decays with gamma.
So you would say alpha
e and alpha g both decay
with half the rate,
but the probability
is for the total rate,
and the coherence
is the product of
the amplitudes.
So therefore when you
look at the coherence,
this decays with 1/2 gamma e.
This decays with 1/2 gamma g,
and this is what you get here,
1/2 gamma in state a,
1/2 gamma in state b.
Whereas the probability
to be in this state
decays with twice that because
the probability is squared.
So you find that pretty much
in any quantum mechanically
corrects derivation,
which you do
about the decay of
population coherences.
Other questions?
So we have done two things.
We have done the very,
very simple derivation
using the beam splitter
model where you may not even
notice where I did the Markov
approximation because I jumped
from beam splitter
to beam splitter
and left all the
correlations behind.
Here in the most
general calculation,
you have seen exactly
where it enters,
but maybe now you have the
full forest in front of you,
and you don't recognize
the trees anymore.
So let me wrap up this
lecture by now focusing
on the system we want
to discuss further on,
namely a two-level system
interacting with a vacuum
through spontaneous emission.
But I also want to make
some generalizations.
I want to give you some
generalizations about what
kind of environments are
possible in quantum physics.
Let me just see how I do that.
So this part I actually owe to
Professor [? Ikschuan ?] who
wonderfully compiled that.
So what I want to
do now is, I want
to call your attention
to the operator
form which, is rather unique.
Remember when we did second
order perturbation theory,
we had sort of the
commutator of v
with the commutator
of v and rho.
This came from iterating
the exact equation of motion
for the density matrix.
And you want to specialize that
now to Jaynes-Cummings model.
I mean, in the end, at
least in this course,
we always come back to
the Jaynes-Cummings model
because it captures a lot
of what we want to explore.
So the Jaynes-Cummings model in
the rotating wave approximation
is very simple.
It raises the atom from
ground to excited state
and destroys a photon,
or it does the opposite.
So this is our
simple interaction
between our system,
the two-level atom
and our reservoir which is just
the vacuum of all the modes.
And you, again, recognize
what I said in general.
You usually always
find it by linear form,
an operator which
acts on the modes,
on the reservoir on the
vacuum, and an operator which
acts on the vacuum.
Now, we want to make
the explicit assumption
that the initial state of the
reservoir is the vacuum state.
It's empty.
And I want to show you
what is the structure
of the operators we obtain.
And so if you put
v into here, you
have first the commutator with
rho, which I write down here,
and then we have to take
another commutator with v.
And the result of
that is the following,
that when it comes
to relaxation pauses,
based on the general
structure of the time
evolution of quantum mechanics,
we have this double commutator.
And the operator which, couples
our system to the environment
is erasing and
lower an operator.
I mean, the atom because it
interacts with the environment
either absolves the photon
or emits the photon.
But those operators, sigma
plus and sigma minus,
appear now always as
products because we
have two occurrences
of the interaction,
v. But if you look at the
double commutator structure,
the operator sigma plus
sigma minus appears.
This is just the
general structure
of this double
commutator appears
to the left side of the
atomic density matrix
to the right side of the
and then there is the coarse
term where the atomic density
matrix is in the
middle of the two.
So this is actually
something which
is very general
and very important
in the theory of
open quantum system.
What I'm discussing with you now
is this famous Lindblad form.
And the story goes like that.
You want to know what are
possible environments, not just
empty vacuum.
You can have fluctuating fields.
You can have, you name it.
But if you are saying that
your environment interacts
with your system
through an operator,
and our operator is now the
operator sigma minus, which
is a spontaneous emission,
you need heavy t.
The mathematical structure
of a valid quantum field
remains that if your system
interacts with an environment
by emitting a
photon sigma minus,
this is now the structure
of the master equation.
This is the structure of the
time evolution of the density
matrix.
So the operator
sigma minus and its
and its Hermitian conjugate
sigma plus, all of this
have to appear in
this combination.
Yes, Collin.
AUDIENCE: This is still
in my interaction picture.
Right?
There's no dynamical
phase evolution
that we put back in there.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
What we do in general if the
system is driven by a laser
beam, for instance,
Rabi oscillation,
we simply add up the dynamics
of the Rabi oscillation
of the unitary time evolution
to the time evolution
done by the reservoir.
AUDIENCE: So this form is always
in the interaction picture?
PROFESSOR: Well, this
is, you would say,
this form is what is
the relaxation provided
by the environment.
And if you drive the
system in addition
with the coherent field,
unitary time evolution,
you would add it to it.
So in other words,
what I'm telling
you here is that this is
the general structure,
and if you have a
system which interacts
with an environment in
five different ways,
with a dipole wand, with a
magnetic moment and such,
you have maybe five
interaction terms
and then you have to perform
the sum over five operators,
and here one of them is
a sigma minus operator.
So in other words,
if you want to know
what is the whole world of
possibilities for quantum
system to relax and dissipate
with an environment,
you can pretty much
take any operator which
acts on your system,
but then put it
into this so-called
Lindblad form
and you have a
possible environment.
And I mentioned
I think last week
that people are now in
our field actively working
on environmental engineering.
They want to expose a system
to an artificial environment
and hope the system is
not relaxing, let's say,
to a broken ground state, but
to a fancy correlated state.
So what this Lindblad form,
if the operators appears
in this way, what it
insures is the following.
Just imagine if we
have an equation,
a derivative of
the density matrix,
which depends on
you could write down a
differential equation and say
is it possible?
Well, it has to be consistent
with quantum physics.
You have certain requirements.
One requirement is that
rho, the density matrix,
always has to be
the density matrix.
The trace equal 1
has to be conserved.
A density matrix always must
have non-negative eigenvalues,
otherwise, what
you write down, it
might be a nice differential
equation, but quantum
mechanically, it's nonsense.
But now there is one more
thing, which is also necessary.
This time evolution of the
system's density matrix
must come from a unitary time
evolution of a bigger system.
So you must be able to extend
your system into a bigger
system, which is
now the environment,
and this whole system must
follow a Schrodinger equation
with a Hamilton as a
unitary time evolution.
And this is where
it's restrictive.
You cannot just write down a
differential equation and hope
that this will fill
some requirement,
and what people have shown is
under very general assumptions,
it is the Lindblad form
which allows for it.
So some operator always
has to appear in this form.
So often in this
Lindblad form, you
have an operator, which is
called a jump operator, which
is responsible for
the measurement, which
the environment
does on your system.
The jump operator is
here, the operator
which takes the atom from the
excited to the ground state.
With that you need a photon,
and the photon can be measured.
So often you can describe a
system by a jump operator,
and if the jump operator is
put into this Lindblad form,
then you have a valid master
equation for your system.
So let me wrap up.
If you take now the definition
of the raising and lowering
operator, and you take the
form I showed you, the Lindblad
form, you'll find now
this differential equation
for your two-level system.
And this is one part of
the Optical Bloch Equation.
Now, coming to
Collin's question,
if you include
the time evolution
of the classical field,
this is a coherent evolution
of the Bloch vector,
which I showed
at the beginning of
the class, and we
add this and what I wrote down
at the beginning of the class.
Then we find the famous
Optical Bloch Equations
in the Jaynes-Cummings model.
So these are now the
Optical Bloch Equations,
and I hope you enjoy now after
this complicated discussion,
how simple they are.
And it is this simple
set of equations,
which will be used in
the rest of the course
to describe the time
evolution of the system.
Just because I did
some generalizations
about the Lindblad equation,
I copied that into the lecture
notes from Wikipedia,
and probably now you
sort of understand what is the
most general Lindblad equation.
It has a Hamiltonian
part and then it
has jump operators like
you sigma minus operator,
but it has to come in
the form that the jump
operator and its complex
conjugate, emission. conjugate,
is on the left side, on the
right side, and left and right
of your density matrix.
So this is the generalization
I've mentioned.
Yeah. with that I think with
that we've derived the master
equation, and on
Wednesday, we will
look at rather simple solutions,
transient and steady-state
solution of the
Optical Bloch Equation.
Any questions?
One reminder about the
schedule, this week
we have a lecture on
Friday because I will not
be on town next
week on Wednesday.
And of course, you know today
in a week, next week on Monday.
It's [INAUDIBLE] day.
So we have three
classes this week,
no class the following week,
and then the normal schedule
for the rest of the semester.